podéis pasar
es un día atípico en la vida de Gladys
hoy sí tenemos luz pero normalmente el
día que no tenemos luz Esto está oscuras
su voz normalmente tranquila y amable se
quiebra al describir la situación que
están viviendo no sé a veces a mí me da
ganas de llorar porque me siento
impotente
tú te levantas a las 3 de la mañana Tú
sigo has estado oscuras ahí durmiendo
el ser humano no
así llevan dos años más de 4000 personas
que viven en los sectores 5 y 6 de
Cañada real galiana a 14 km del centro
de Madrid una antigua vía de paso de
ganado que fue ocupada poco a poco hasta
convertirse en una zona con más de 7.000
personas lo que algunos llaman
asentamiento irregular es para los
vecinos su barrio
Rosario con 82 años vive aquí desde los
que yo tengo aquí todo el trabajo que yo
por ejemplo que he hecho que he ahorrado
en mi vida Yo tengo uno duro del banco
entre comillas y todo lo que ahorraba
para la casa para la casa mis hermanos
Pedro Navarrete era el comisionado del
ayuntamiento de Madrid para la cañada
real Cuando en 2017 se firmó el pacto
que garantizaba unos servicios básicos
hasta encontrar una solución de Real ojo
o de regularización definitiva desde el
cambio de mando En la alcaldía en 2019
se está incumpliendo
cortándole la luz cortándoles el
suministro de agua haciendo todo lo que
sea posible para hacerle la vida
imposible Y que mañana acepten cualquier
tipo de realojo por muy sangrante que
sea para familias que tienen aquí su
arraigo la descalifica la situación de
chantaje emocional pero asegura que ella
no se irá de su hogar Seguiremos
luchando por nuestro barrio por nuestras
casas por nuestro por el futuro de
nuestros hijos más que todo un futuro en
el que la luz también sea un derecho
para la cañada real